2020 va être une année où une fois de
plus le nécessaire et possible et où l
ambition va rester notre notre chemin
c'est d'une année eux nous allons encore
et là enfin concrétisé un certain nombre
de nos engagements et report fait partie
de ces choses très concrètes et s'il
fallait en citer d'autres l'aréna cette
grande salle que tout le monde attend
visiblement en tout cas la première
pierre sera posée ici au printemps nous
poseront la première pierre de
l'historial le 25 juin je voudrais
saint-alby nord et puis la première
pierre du collège de vouneuil sous biard
qui aura posé je crois l'un d'ici la fin
de l'année avec un plan collège qui a
été largement enrichie cette dernière
semaine des choses concrètes s'annonce
et s'il en fallait en citer une autre
marie-jeanne lundi les casernes de
pompiers dont on a tant parlé là encore
depuis des décennies vont enfin ouvrir
les réaliser et donc complètement
refaite à saint-éloi s'est aussi dit
encore quand on aime on compte un
milliard cent millions mis pour les
dépenses de solidarité parce que c'est
notre première responsabilité et vous le
savez nous venons d'adopter un schéma
unique de solidarité pour faire encore
plus aux côtés des personnes âgées des
personnes handicapées en matière de
protection de l'enfance département
restera le premier financeur des
collectivités le premier partenaire
parce que c'est pas forcément de jour
des questions de budget qu'on s'engage
avec vous mais c'est bien sûr le mandat
si la paix maintenant comme on le fait
déjà depuis de nombreuses années moi je
crois sans engagement j'ai demandé aux
services du département que si cet été
nous soyons capables de présenter aux
équipes municipales une carte où ils
nous diront quand la fibre optique sera
chez vous installez et votre engagement
que je prends devant vous parce que je
crois que c'est fondamental c'est de
dire que 80 % des communes de la vienne
soient équipés en fibre optique d'ici
vous savez avec pascal guittèye à
l'aréna label leuthard de jeu mais il ya
effectivement tout le plan esprit jeu
que nous allons développer durant les
quatre années de l'olympiade qui ouvre
qui s'ouvre à partir de doute 2020 voilà
les défis qui s'annoncent à annuler
parce que de la ruralité à la fibre là
marchés est grande mais en tout cas nous
souhaitons être actif sur tous ces
sujets là parce qu'ils sont fondamentaux
pour le territoire